los viajeros vacunados y que provengan
de eeuu o de la unión europea ya no
tendrán que hacer cuarentena al ingresar
a gran bretaña
las nuevas medidas entrarán en vigencia
el próximo lunes la decisión se da
después de que el primer ministro
afirmara que quería que los
estadounidenses pudieran entrar
libremente inglaterra
jobim aníbal habrá muchos beneficios
poder tener abiertas nuestras fronteras
para que las personas puedan entrar sin
embargo la clave es proteger a los
británicos soy consciente de que esto
viene primero que todo no podemos acabar
con los sacrificios que hemos hecho
hasta ahora
mientras que los contagios porque hoy 19
han caído desde la semana pasada el
número de muertes diarias alcanzó su
máximo desde marzo
es una buena noticia escuchar que los
casos han descendido pero si miramos las
cifras del acceso a los hospitales están
aumentando exponencialmente
podríamos pensar que estamos en el punto
en el que miramos hacia adelante y
creemos que esta pandemia es una cosa
del pasado pero ese punto en realidad no
ha llegado todavía
a pesar de no tener que hacer una
cuarentena las personas de estas zonas
deberán hacerse una prueba de kobe 19
antes del viaje y al segundo día después
de llegar al reino unidos